why is it that the world we're told in
america now has begun
1619 and not 1776
critical race theory uh critical
immigration theory
um the the attack on capitalism with the
d
growth movement the climate change move
all these things what are they
why did they kind of just spring up in
the last 20 30 years and especially
our focus this year and last year and
the reason is
and i'm going to use the word these
these are marxist-based ideologies
if people understand karl marx they
understand his writings they understand
his background and i've studied him very
very thoroughly for a project i'm
working on
he was a journalist people don't even
know he was a journalist he had many
articles that appeared in the
new york sun he was a
classical liberal for a period of time
and then something happened
you mentioned sort of libertarian to
conservative
to constitutional conservative what was
it as you know i i've sort of brought
the phrase classical liberal back and
that that was what my book was about and
people always say to me well dave is
there any really
meaningful distinction between classical
liberal and libertarian so actually let
me start with that do you do you
see any meaningful distinction or or
have the labels and words all become
sort of muddled in in modern times
well they can be uh but they're in the
same they're in the right
area in other words not right
philosophical in the correct area
you know i've always uh libertarian
conservative libertarian conservative
conservative libertarian
it's like scalia and thomas
they both wrote opinions sometimes they
would agree sometimes they would
disagree
but the way they approached the issue is
what is key
what is it that drives your thinking
what are your principles behind your
thinking
and so i was once asked i think was by
ben
as a matter of fact on his show he said
when you interpret the constitution do
you do it from a libertarian point of
view or conservative point of view or
how do you approach it
i said well libertarianism and
conservatism are
philosophies interpreting the
constitution is interpreting the
constitution
that is you're not supposed to bring a
philosophy to it
you're supposed to try and discern what
the framers
meant and what the words meant at the
time
so i don't get into this am i
conservative liberal
libertarian when i interpret the
constitution's the constitution
so why do i call myself a constitutional
conservative
i have many libertarian beliefs
but i call myself a constitutional
conservative because
of the thinking and the arguments and so
forth and people understand that went
behind the constitution itself
the debates are we don't want a mob we
don't want a monarchy we don't want
these things we don't want direct
democracy we don't want factions what do
we want we want a republic
and they developed the most fascinating
and i hope lasting uh republic that man
has ever created
so are there differences well of course
they're differences
libertarians fight with conservatives
all the time you know guys like
hayak and mises they had no stomach for
conservatives
uh these the austrian school on the
other hand milton friedman did
he's one of my great heroes and so uh
we're going to argue over libertarian
versus conservative i'm fine
we're going to argue over americanism
versus marxism
that's a whole nother i think we're
going to be okay on whatever the
marginal
libertarian conservative differences are
so let's put that aside but you know
every every way that you just sort of
answered that question
what sort of sat beneath it was you have
great reverence for the founding
documents for the founders
for our history and it seems to me we
live in a time
where that is just i mean you actually
said hope that was
meaning that you hope that these things
will still matter but we in essence live
in a time where
we're we're erasing all of that at a
rapidly increasing pace
yeah and i'll get into this a little bit
i've been thinking about this too we are
and why is that why is it that the world
we're told in america now has begun
1619 and not 1776
critical race theory uh critical
immigration theory
um the the attack on capitalism with the
d
growth movement the climate change move
all these things what are they
why did they kind of just spring up in
the last 20 30 years and especially
our focus this year and last year and
the reason is
and i'm going to use the word these are
marxist-based ideologies
if people understand karl marx they
understand his writings they understand
his background
i've studied him very very thoroughly
for a project i'm working on
he was a journalist people don't even
know he was a journalist he had many
articles that appeared in the
new york sun he was a
classical liberal for a period of time
and then something happened he saw
things
and he abandoned it and then he
developed his
ideology really based on rousseau and
hegel and those guys and he just
he just moved it towards materialism and
he just
um he was an angry man he was a poor man
he always relied on his lawyer father
and his friend angles to subsidize him
and i think to my and by the way people
don't realize for 30 40 years after he
died nobody cared about marx
except american progressives who were
fixated with him
um but all that said i uh
i'm of the attitude that with the early
progressives
dewey wilson crowley
all these guys and more they said
basically we need to change education in
america
it's not enough to teach mathematics and
history and english without
a social construct without an
understanding and putting it in a
cultural perspective
and that's what they did they
fundamentally altered
public education which became bigger and
bigger and then they altered
colleges and universities you know back
then as i recall about six percent of
the population
graduated from college today it's about
34 35 percent
and so they felt as elites
and so-called intellectuals that is
where they can make the biggest change
and they have
they fundamentally altered the way at
least half the country looks at this
country
and as you know marx wanted a clean
slate
so our history is to be attacked our
history is to be degraded our history is
to be rejected
so whereas somebody like me and you we
look at our history in ancient history
in all history in order to try and
figure out what what is mankind about
where should we be or
are we doing the right things does this
make sense they don't
so antifa black lives matter leftist
period
they attack american history they reject
what the framers did
i'm going on here a little bit dave but
you know no no i'm with you well you're
talking about the
the slow march through the institution
so what do you do then so if we're
at that strange place now and you know
35 of these of the kids that now go to
college
that so now you've got 35 as opposed to
six percent what do you say that was
just a couple decades ago in essence
um well that's an awful lot of
brainwashed people coming out of these
schools what do you do
in an age of social media and in an age
of you know a culture war
we have to begin to use the left's
tactics against the left
i believe this very strong i never used
to believe this
i used to preach free market capitalism
i still believe in it
uh all these other things and they're
very very important
but tactically we're going to have to
get active
we're going to have to do things we've
never done before
because marxism is a constant revolution
conservatism or constitutional
conservatism
is a stand in place and so
they're always on the move and we're
always on defense
if we're doing anything at all i look at
it with the democrat and republican
party it's not a precise parallel but
the democrat party is always
breaking windows the republican party is
always sitting in rocking chairs
you know just watching it and so
this has to change now i can't control
the republican party
and i think that's why a lot of people
like trump because wittingly or not
he would break windows when they would
break windows and wow there's a guy
finally
who's fighting for these things but also
um
i think more and more of us in our
individual lives
are going to have to become activists i
don't mean violent activists i mean
activists i
uh in everyday things that we do where
we choose to buy things
when we talk to neighbors form groups to
go to school boards do all these sorts
of things
start pressuring our legislatures where
we have friendly legislatures
to pass laws like they do in florida to
address big tech
we need to be on offense we need to
bring litigation we need to throw as
much against
them as they throw against us and do
everything we possibly can i mean the
nation was founded
by men who who
who took a very activist role in their
lives they were pushed to a point
and of course the difference between the
marxists that we deal with now and us
is they want to destroy our society
yeah you know that that's interesting
the french revolution they wanted to
destroy their society the russian
revolution the communist
the chinese rebel they all wanted to
destroy their system the american
revolution wanted to preserve our
society
and change the government um what's
happening here
is we're up against street marxists or
mobs or whatever you want to call them
that want to destroy our society
and uh are demeaning our society as
the crt folks you know we're white
dominant society so everything related
to it is bigoted and racist which is so
absurd
and i just think we need to stand up and
say enough
we need to push back everybody has a
different role in this life
some people electricians some are bus
drivers some do what we do and so forth
but all of us in some role in our life
whether it's our purchasing power
whether it's school board meetings
churches synagogue we've got to speak up
we've got to be heard and we've got to
organize
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell